[Music]
hey sweetie you okay
there's this new app i heard about and
it could be handy in case you okay i'll
check it out
just a little step yep i got it
hi
hi
please come in
all of our cheese food is in the pantry
i can show you i'll find it thanks
ciao
[Music]
download c for me
hey what can i do for you hi i'm locked
out do you see a way i can get back in
uh let's move around the perimeter
you're right in front of a sliding glass
door can you feel it
be careful sophie
[Music]
someone's here
hey how can i help you it's me sophie
there's people in the house
they're looking for me just stay calm
[Applause]
where are they now
close
if you stay down you can make it
[Music]
we need to get you to the basement and
wait for the cops
is there anything in my way wait sophie
wait
she dialed 9-1-1 12 minutes ago he said
the place was gonna be empty i can get
rid of the cops
and why would you do that
who's gonna suspect a little blind girl
right
could you open the door please
they're gonna kill you no one's going
anywhere
i swear we can do this
you just need to trust me
he's in the room
let him get a little closer to you
inhale
and on my mark
fire
[Music]
[Music]
you